So, we have a two-part
lecture series to finish The Divine
Comedy.
So, uh today we start part one, and then
next Wednesday we do part two.
So, The Divine Comedy
is the most influential work of
literature
in European history. Why? Because
Dante's Comedy will give rise to the
Protestant Reformation,
as well as the
Scientific Revolution,
the Enlightenment,
Renaissance,
basically modernity itself.
Okay?
So, the question is, how did Dante
accomplish this?
He accomplished this basically by
responding to Virgil.
Okay? So, for the longest time, for
about a thousand years, Virgil was the
most dominant thinker
in European history.
And Virgil's Aeneid, which we read,
becomes the basis for Augustine.
Um he wrote two major books, Confessions
and City of God.
And this will become the basis of the
Catholic Church.
All right? So, how did Virgil come to
become the soul of the Catholic Church?
With the He came
up with the idea
of
human nature. Okay?
So, Augustine will emphasize the idea of
original sin.
Okay, so the original sin was
an act of disobedience when Adam and Eve
ate from the
tree of the fruit or sorry, the the tree
of knowledge, okay? They ate the fruit
from the tree of knowledge. That's an
act of disobedience because God
explicitly said, "You can do whatever
you want in this garden of Eden, but
don't eat that fruit." And they
disobeyed God.
And Augustine points out that
what compelled this original sin is
pride.
We humans cannot bear
to serve God, to be humble before God.
We
seek
to overthrow God.
And so God had no choice but to punish
us.
Okay? So, what drives this original sin?
What drives this original sin is that
yes, it is true that God
he breathed life into us, okay? He
breathed life into us
so that our soul
is the divine spark. That is true.
The problem though is that our bodies
are made from dust.
Okay? Dust.
And as a result
because we are dust, we strive for
dirty things such as lust,
uh pride,
gluttony,
sloth. Okay, the seven deadly sins.
Okay? And we can't we can't help
ourselves.
And the only way to repair the world,
the only way for us to seek salvation
and redemption, the only path to heaven
is obedience, okay? What
uh Virgil will call piety.
And so, as long as we are loyal to the
Catholic Church, we'll be fine. The
Catholic Church will guide us
like a shepherd guides his flock to
heaven. But, what's really important to
understand is that our nature is dirty.
We are sinful by nature, and therefore,
we can't trust our own intuition.
Okay? And this This becomes a framework
for medieval Europe, which lasts about
1,000 years, and this is what led to
something called the Dark Ages, when
basically the entire world surpassed
Europe in terms of innovation, wealth,
um
and intellectual creativity.
So, what Dante's going to do is he's
going to assert
the power and the truth of individual
intuition.
Okay? So, the major argument that
Dante's is going to make is that, yes,
it is true that we are made of dust. It
is true that we have bodies.
We
uh seek pleasures.
But,
that divine spark in us,
it never went away.
And much more importantly, that divine
spark still connects us to God.
Okay? So, as long as we're able to
activate this divine spark, we can
be imaginative. We can seek truth for
ourselves. We don't need the Catholic
Church.
All right? So, Dante, what he's doing is
he's
um asserting the primacy of love.
We don't need
to obey others. We don't need the church
because love, if we just activate the
love with within us, this will connect
us back to God. And this connection will
drive our imagination, which will make
us creative. And creativity
is the ultimate purpose of the universe.
Okay?
So, what what I will do in this two-part
two-part lecture series is the first
part, look at Virgil, what the argument
he's making, okay? And then
um on Wednesday, I will continue with
Dante.
All right? So, any questions so far
about this framework?
Okay. So, again, the argument the debate
it's very simple. Is human nature
fundamentally good or bad?
Okay, if you think it's bad, then you
need to create a hierarchy to to control
human behavior. But if you if like
Dante, you're optimistic,
um
then you don't need to control human
behavior. In fact, you want to encourage
individual intuition as much as
possible, okay? So, that's a fundamental
debate.
All right. So, um let's look at the
basic structure of the Divine Comedy,
okay? So, we've read the entirety of
Inferno.
Okay? And from Inferno, Virgil and Dante
will go to
Purgatory, where
souls will cleanse themselves of sins so
that they are ready to go to Paradise.
Okay? So, we're going to look at
Purgatory today, and then next class
we'll look at Paradise.
All right. So, Purgatory is modeled very
much
uh in a very similar way as the Inferno,
okay? So, the wonderful thing about the
Divine Comedy is it's structured. It's
very visual. So, in Purgatory, what you
do is first of all, you enter Purgatory,
okay? You enter Purgatory. But the
moment you enter Purgatory, what an
angel who guards the Purgatory will do
is stamp seven P's
onto you, okay? Each P represents a sin.
And so, what you do is you climb each
terrace of this mountain, and each
terrace
um has an a particular sin, okay? So,
terrace one is pride, terrace two is
envy, terrace three is anger, terrace
four is laziness, terrace five is
covetousness, terrace six is gluttony,
and terrace seven is lust, okay? So,
it's almost like the inverse of Inferno.
>> [snorts]
>> And so, each time you clear a terrace by
absolving yourself, by cleansing
yourself of a particular sin, a P is
removed from your forehead. And once you
remove all P's, you climb up to
essentially the Garden of Eden up here.
And then, up here, what's going to
happen is that Beatrice is going to
descend from heaven and pick Dante up so
that they can
ascend to heaven together, okay?
So, Virgil is going to guide
um Dante through the process
of Purgatory and then leave Dante to
Beatrice. Okay, that that that's the
basic structure of
um Purgatory. Any questions so far?
All right.
All right. So, we're going to start
reading, okay?
All right. So, again, remember that the
fundamental difference between Dante and
Virgil is that Virgil is ultimately
skeptical about human nature, whereas
Dante is optimistic. Okay, so we're
we're first going to figure out what
Virgil's argument is. Okay, so Avery,
can you read please?
>> And even as I turned towards him, I
asked, "What did the spirit of Romagna
mean when he said 'sharing cannot have a
part'"? And his reply, "He knows the
harm that lies in his worst vice. If he
chastises it
to ease its expiation, do not wonder.
For when your longings center on things
such as sharing, then then portions less
to each, then envy stirs the bellows of
her sighs.
But if the love within the highest
sphere should turn your longings
heavenward,
the fear inhabiting your breast would
disappear. For there, the more there are
who would say "ours", so much the
greater is the good possessed by each,
so much more love burns in that
cloister.
>> Okay, stop. Okay, all right. So,
um what So, they're they're are in the
terrace of envy.
And here people must expiate themselves
of their
envy of others. And envy comes from
misguidance, okay?
People are focused on the material
world.
And in the material world,
things are finite, right?
So, we struggle over food, over water,
over wealth.
But if we focus on the spiritual world,
if we focus on God,
>> [snorts]
>> okay, the spiritual,
then resources are infinite, okay?
And in the spiritual world, the more you
share with others, the more wealth is
created.
Okay? Because you're uplifting each
other's spirit.
So, that's the difference between the
material world and the spiritual world,
where in the material world, sharing can
be punished because it's a zero-sum
game. If someone has an apple, you don't
have it. If you have that apple, someone
else doesn't have it.
But in the spiritual world,
um we're focused on love, generosity,
forgiveness. The more you love, the more
generous you are, the more generosity
creates in the world, right? If you
smile at someone, that other person
smiles back at you. You're kind to that
person, that person is kind to others.
All right? So, that is the
misconception. That's why people have
envy because they are ignorant of the
nature of the universe.
Envy is too much of a focus on the
material world, and to expiate yourself
of envy, you must focus on the spiritual
world. Okay? So, here Virgil and Dante
do not disagree. Keep on going.
>> I am more hungry now for satisfaction, I
said,
>> I I of course it's Dante, right? Keep on
going.
>> than if I had held my tongue before. I
host a deeper doubt within my mind.
How can a good that's that's shared by
more possessors enable each to be more
rich in it than if that good had been
possessed by few?
And he to me,
But if you still persist in letting your
mind fix on earthly things, then even
from true light you gather darkness.
That good, ineffable and infinite, which
is above, directs itself towards love as
light directs itself to polished bodies.
Where ours are,
that good gives of itself, and where
more love is, where more love is, there
that good confers a greater measure of
eternal worth.
And when there are more souls above who
love, there's more to love well there,
and they love more, and mirror-like each
soul reflects the other.
And if my speech does not appease your
hunger, you will see Beatrice. She will
fulfill this [snorts] and all other
longings that you feel.
Now only strive so that the other five
wounds may be canceled quickly as the
healing we are. The wounds contrition
heals.
>> Okay. All right. So,
what he's saying here is that the
spiritual world is the good, right? God,
basically.
And so, the more
um kindness, the more love you generate
to other people, they reflect that.
And that spreads
love and kindness all around the
universe, okay? So, when we need to
visualize this, it's with something
called Indra's net.
And this is a concept from Hinduism and
Buddhism, okay? So, what is a soul? Who
are we? Well, we are a pearl in a
universe of pearl of pearls, okay? It's
a net. And the thing about a pearl is
that it reflects everything. So, within
us, we reflect the universe.
Okay? So, within us is the universe,
okay? So, do you guys see this?
And the idea here is that our souls are
a fractal
of the universe. And therefore, whatever
we do
is reflected throughout the entire
universe, okay? If this pearl chooses to
smile, every other pearl reflects that
smile. If this pearl chooses to be
angry, that the other pearls
become angry as well. That's why
um
being sinful or being good is so
important, because literally
we have the entire fate of the universe
in our hearts.
Okay?
So, again
um
Dante and Virgil do not disagree here.
So, do you guys understand the concept
here? This is very important for Dante,
okay?
And this concept is something that we
expand it on when we get to paradise.
That we are just a reflection of the
entire universe.
All right, can you continue, Aubrey?
>> Tell me, my gentle father, what offense
is purged within the circle we have
reached? Although our feet must stop,
your words need not.
And he to me,
"Precisely here, the love of good that
is too tepidly pursued is mended. Here
the lazy hour applies harder.
But so that you may understand more
clearly, now turn your mind to me, and
you will gather some useful fruit from
our delaying here.
My son, there is no creator and no
creature who ever was without love,
natural or mental, and you know that.
>> Okay, so here the idea of love
is just a reflection of God. Okay,
remember God breathed his life into
Adam, and so we have the aspect of God
in us. Okay, so everything has love in
it. The question is the degree of love,
and the question is how impact is love
in our lives. Okay, keep on going.
>> Natural is always without error, but
mental love may choose an evil object or
errs through it too much or too little
vigor.
As long as it's directed towards the
first good and tends towards secondary
goods with measure, it cannot be the
cause of evil pleasure.
But when it twists towards evil or
attends to good with more or less care
than it should,
those whom he made have worked against
their maker.
>> Wait, stop. Okay, so this is the idea of
a dual duality, right? Where you have
the soul,
and the soul is pure love, and it comes
from the divine, and it's eternal.
Therefore, it's always good. The problem
is that the soul is inside a body, okay?
The body is made of dust,
and as a result, it's constantly
striving towards evil. And so within us
is this constant conflict between the
soul and the body, which seeks material
pleasures, which basically seeks uh sin.
All right? And again, what Virgil will
say is honestly, most of us basically
cannot
uh withstand the temptation, and that's
why we need the church, an authority,
and obedience. Okay, keep on going.
>> From this you see that, of necessity,
love is a seed in you of every virtue
and of all acts deserving punishment.
Now, since love never turns aside its
eyes from the well-being of its subject,
things are surely free from hatred of
themselves. And since no being can be
seen as self-existing and divorced from
the first being,
each creature is cut off from hating
him.
Thus, if I have distinguished properly,
ill love must mean to wish one's
neighbor ill, and this love's foreign in
three ways in your clay.
There is he who, through abasement of
another, hopes for supremacy.
He only longs to see his neighbor's
excellence cast down.
Then there is one who, when he's
outdone, fears his own loss of fame,
power, honor, favor, whose sadness loves
mis- misfortune for his neighbor.
And there's who There There is he who,
over injury received, resentful, for
revenge grows greedy and angrily seeks
out another's harm.
>> Okay. All right. So, again, the original
sin is a sin of pride, okay? So, what
Virgil is saying here is, "Look, it's
impossible for you to hate God because
God is the ultimate good. It's
impossible for you to hate yourself. So,
the hate comes from your envy of others,
your pride, the fact that you want to
stand above other people. And if other
people are above you, then you you
conspire against them, and that's the
source of all sin, okay?
All right. Let's keep on going.
>> This threefold love is as expiated here
below.
Now, I would have you understand the
love that seeks the good distortedly.
Each apprehends confusedly a good in
which the mind may rest and longs for
it, and thus all strive to reach that
good.
But if the love that urges you to know
it or to reach that good is lax, this
terrace after it adjusts repentance
punishes for that.
There is a different good, which does
not make men glad. It is not happiness,
is not true essence, fruit and root of
every good.
The love that prof- profligately
yields to that as whipped on three
terraces on the three terraces above us,
but I'll not say what three shapes that
love takes. May you seek those
distinctions for yourself.
>> Okay. All right.
So, the purpose of purgatory is for us
to cleanse ourselves of our material
wants and desires. Okay? To focus on the
spiritual. To remember where we came
from and to remember our connection with
the good that will allow us to access
heaven at the end, okay? Keep on going.
>> The subtle teacher had completed his
discourse to me. Attentively, he watched
my eyes to see if I seemed satisfied.
And I, still goaded by new thirst, was
silent without, although within I said,
"Perhaps I have displeased him with too
many questions."
But that true father, who had recognized
a timid want that I would not tell aloud
by speaking, gave me courage to speak
out.
At which I said, "Master, my sight is
still illumined by your light. I
recognize all that your words have
clarified.
Therefore, I pray you, gentle father
dear,
to teach me what love is. You have
reduced to love both each good and its
opposite."
>> Okay. So, basically, what Virgil is
saying is that love is the fundamental
force of the universe. If we move away
from love, we do bad things. If we move
towards love, we do good things. Okay?
So, now Dante is like, "Then tell me
exactly what love is. Be specific about
love." All right?
>> He said, "Direct your intellect's sharp
eyes toward me, and let the error of the
blind who served who serve as guides be
evident to you.
The soul, which is created quick to
love, responds everything that pleases
just as soon as beauty awakens it to
act.
Your apprehension draws an image from a
real object and expands upon that object
until soul has turned toward it. And if
so turned, the soul tends steadfastly,
then that propensity is love. It's
nature that joins the soul anew and anew
through beauty.
Then, just as flames ascend because the
form of fire was fashioned to fly
upwards towards the stuff of its own
sphere where it lasts longest, so does
the soul, when seized, move into
longing, a motion of the spirit, never
resting till the beloved thing has made
it joyous.
>> Okay, okay, so this is really important,
okay? So, let's try to understand what
he's saying here.
So, the soul comes from the divine,
okay? It is a memory of God.
And it is inside a
body, okay?
A body that allows it to experience the
world. This body confuses the soul, and
the soul is lost. And the soul believes
that whatever is beautiful, I must seek,
okay? So, the soul, if you leave it
alone, it's going to it's going to want
to return to God. But,
if it sees something beautiful, okay?
It doesn't know
if it should if it's good or bad, okay?
All All it knows is like, I want to go
to it. So, what happens is the soul
expands outwards and tries to encompass
it.
And then what it does is it moves
towards it and tries to swallow it
whole. It consumes it, okay?
Right? So, think of Dido and Aeneas,
where Dido sees Aeneas in the Aeneid,
falls in love with him, and he must have
him, okay? He moves towards him and
tries to consume him. It drives her
insane. And the moment he leaves her,
she has to kill herself.
Okay? So, that's the issue with the
soul. The soul moves towards what's
beautiful. And it doesn't even know why
it's doing so.
And when it moves, it tries to
absorb and consume it, okay? Because if
it because
that's what it was trained to do, right?
God created it so that the soul would
one day return to God.
But because as a body, the soul becomes
confused. And if it sees a beautiful
woman,
the soul is like, I must have her. I
must have sex with her. It doesn't
matter if I rape her. It doesn't matter
if I marry her. I don't really care. But
I must have her. I must control her,
okay? I must consume her.
All right, keep on going.
>> Now you can plainly see how deeply
hidden truth is from
who would insist that every love is in
itself praiseworthy.
And they are led to error by the matter
of love because it may seem always good,
but not each seal is fine although the
wax is.
Your speech and my own wit that followed
it, I answered again, have shown me what
love is. But that has that has filled
filled me with still greater doubts. For
if love's offered to us from without and
is the only foot with which soul walks,
soul going straight or crooked has no
merit.
And he to me, what reason can can see
here I can impart past that for truth of
faith. It's spiritual truth alone you
must await.
Every substantial form at once distinct
from matter and conjoint to it and
gathers a force that is distinct to be
its own.
The force unknown to us until it acts is
never shown except in its effects just
as green sprouts
boughs display the life in plants.
>> Okay, so Dante's confused by this
formulation because if we are trying to
consume something that we love,
then how can we know
what's good and what's evil?
Right? What is the mechanism that tells
us what's good and what's evil? The soul
is doing what it must do, right? The
soul must
seek out what's beautiful and consume
it. The soul thinks that whatever is
beautiful must be God.
But if it gets confused and think that a
woman
is beautiful and the soul tries to
control that woman, then that's a bad
thing, right?
So, why would God create a system in
which
you are naturally compelled to do evil?
All right?
And
uh
can I go on going?
>> And thus, man does not know the source
of his intelligence, the primal notions,
and is tending towards desires, primal
objects.
Both are in you just as in bees, there
is the honey-making urge. Such primal
will deserves no praise and and it
deserves no blame.
Now, though all other longings may
conform to this first will, there is in
you, inborn, the power that
counsels, keeper of the threshold of
your ascent.
This is the principle on which your
merit may be judged, for it garners and
winnows good and evil longings.
Those reasoners who reach the roots of
things learn from this inborn learn of
this inborn freedom,
the bequest that thus they left onto the
worlds if is ethics.
Even if we allow necessity of source of
every love that flames in you, the power
to curb that love is still your own.
This noble power is what Beatrice means
by free will, therefore remember it if
she should ever speak of it to you.
>> Okay, the power to curb that love is
still your own.
This is This is what what free will is,
okay?
So, here's the logic here. The logic is
love is not good or bad.
Okay?
It is natural part of you. It's like an
animal desires food. Is that good or
bad? It's just who we are.
So, in this circumstance, what is good?
What is good is our capacity to control
our emotions.
Right? In other words, obedience
is good.
Obedience is what is free will.
Okay?
If we're able to shift from emotions
to reason,
that is good. What is reason? Reason is
the capacity to restrain our emotions by
obeying authority. It's It's only
authority that allows us to control
ourselves. Do you know what's right and
wrong, okay? And this And this was the
essence. This was the main message of
the Aeneid, right? Aeneas is on a
mission to found Empire. He goes from
Troy to Carthage to the Italian
Peninsula. But it's actually a spiritual
journey because when he starts his
journey, he's very emotional. He sees
Helen.
Um and he wants to kill Helen because he
thinks that Helen is the person who
caused the destruction of of Troy.
Troy's being destroyed and Aeneas wants
to fight the Greeks and die in the
process because he wants to save his
homeland even though it's being
destroyed, okay? He goes to Carthage.
And he's not supposed to be the act
Carthage. He falls in love with Dido and
he wants to stay there. And each time
the gods have to come and say, "Hey,
man,
listen, you have a mission to do. Go Go
You have to go to um Italy in order to
found Rome, okay?" So, and then towards
the end of the uh Aeneid, Aeneas
recognizes his mission is to obey the
gods.
He has He can no longer obey his
emotions. Therefore, But the end, when
he's fighting Turnus and Turnus is
defeated, he wants to show mercy to
Turnus because Turnus has become very
pitiful, but he recognizes, "No, I
cannot allow my emotions sway me. I
cannot trust my intuition. I can never
ever show love to others. I must obey
the gods. I must obey my mission. I must
be reasonable." And so he kills Turnus,
and that's how the Aeneid ends, okay?
Does that make sense?
That is the main argument that Virgil is
making. It is not love that defines who
we are, it's reason that defines who we
are, reason as defined by obedience. If
we are able to obey, that demonstrates
our free will,
okay?
All right.
So, let's let's move on to another
passage, okay? Keep on going.
>> Natural thirst that could never be
quenched except by water that gives
grace. The drought the simple woman of
Samaria sought
tormented me. He spurred me on the path
of crowded souls behind my guide, and I
felt pity, though their pain was
justified.
And here, even as Luke records for us
that Christ knew, risen from his burial
cave, appeared to two along his way.
A shade appeared, and he advanced behind
our backs while we were careful not to
trample on the outstretched crowd.
We did not notice him until he had
addressed us with,
"God give you, oh my brothers, peace."
We turned at once, then after after
offering suitable response, Virgil
began,
"And may that just tribunal May that
just tribunal which has consigned me to
eternal exile place you in peace within
the blessed assembly."
>> Okay, so what's happening here is that
Virgil and Dante are making their way up
the mountain, okay? And there's seven
terraces, and a soul has to clear all
seven terraces before the soul can enter
paradise. When a soul
is able to complete the mission, the
entire mountain shakes, okay?
It is an earthquake to signal that a
soul has been cleansed of all sins is
now is now about to ascend. So, there's
a shade, okay, who is in a rush to
ascend to heaven because he he's cleared
all seven terraces. And so, he's going
to rush to heaven. It's been 500 years.
Um and so, he's going to and he so, he
meets Virgil and Dante. They're in his
way and they're like, "Excuse me,
please. I'm on my way." And Virgil's
like, "Okay.
Um sure. All right."
I'm going.
>> "What?" he exclaimed as we moved forward
quickly.
"If God's not deemed you worthy of
ascent, who's guided you so far along
the stairs?"
"If you observe the signs the angel
traced upon this man," my teacher said,
"you'll see plainly. He's meant to reign
with all the righteous. But since But
since he she who spins right and nights
and day had not yet spin spun the spool
that Clotho sets upon the distaff the
staff and a dress for everyone, his
soul, the sister of your soul and mine
in in his ascent could not alone have
climbed here for it does not see the way
we see.
Therefore, I was brought forth from
hell's broad jaws to guide him in his
going.
I shall lead him just as far as where I
teach can reach. But tell me, if you
can, why just before the mountain shook
and shouted all of it, for so it seemed,
down to the sea bathed shore?"
>> Okay, so the soul is confused because
um if you reach this point in the
mountain, then you're going to heaven.
So, you should be going as fast as
possible.
And then, Virgil's trying to explain
that actually
um
they are not part of purgatory, okay?
Keep on going.
>> His question threaded so the needle's
eye of my desire that just the hope
alone of knowing left my thirst more
satisfied.
The other shade began,
the sanctity of these slopes does not
suffer anything that's without order or
uncustomary.
This place is free from every
perturbation.
What heaven from itself and in itself
receives may serve as cause here,
nothing else.
Therefore, no rain, no hail, no snow, no
dew, no hoarfrost falls here any higher
than the stairs of entry with their
three brief steps.
Neither thick cloud nor thin appear, nor
flash of lightning.
Thamus' daughter, who so often shifts
place in your world, is absent here.
Dry vapor cannot climb any higher than
to the top of the three steps of which I
spoke,
where Peter's vicar plants his feet.
Below that point, there may be small or
ample tre- tremors,
but here above, I know not why, no one
concealed in earth has ever caused a
tremor, for only it trembles here when
some soul feels it's cleansed, so that
it rises or stirs to climb on high, and
that soul follows.
>> Okay, so the mountain only moves if a
soul has been cleansed, okay?
>> The will alone is proof of purity and
fully free surprises soul into a change
of dwelling place effective
>> Okay, so this is a really important
idea, right? So, what's driving
uh this cleansing is just the will. If
you have the will, you can always
achieve heaven,
okay? So, people in inferno, the reason
why they're there is they choose to be
there. Peo- People in purgatory are
there because they choose to be there as
well. It may take you a long time, but
if you have the will, you can always
cleanse yourself of all your sins. God
is all forgiving. Okay, keep keep on
going.
>> Soul had the will to climb before, but
that will was opposed by longing to do
penance
as once to sin instilled by divine
justice.
>> Okay, this is a very important, okay
guys? The issue is not that God has not
forgiven us. The issue is that we have
not forgiven ourselves. Do you
understand? We want to do penance in
order to make ourselves worthy of God.
Okay, keep on going.
>> And I who have lain in this suffering
500 years and more
just now have felt my free will for a
better better threshold.
Thus, you heard the earthquake in the
pious spirits throughout the mountain as
they praised the Lord, and may he send
them speedily upward.
So did he speak to us, and just as joy
is greater when we quench a greater
thirst, the joy he brought cannot be
told in words.
And my wise guide,
I now can see the necks did not impede
impeding you, how one slips through, and
why quakes here, and what makes you all
rejoice.
And now may it please please you to tell
me who you were,
>> [snorts]
>> and in your words may I find why you've
lain here for so many centuries.
>> Okay, so this is a really important
correction to Virgil's understanding,
okay? Virgil believes that a soul
moves to whatever is beautiful, okay? So
obviously if you're close to God, you
want to go to God as soon as possible.
But this person here is saying, "No,
that's not true actually. The soul, yes,
wants to move to God, but the soul is
love.
If you truly love God, you must first
love yourself. That means cleansing
yourself of all sins so that you are
worthy to be with God, okay? So love
seems to be also restraint
and judgment. And this is very different
from Virgil who believes that love is
incapable of restraint and judgment.
Okay? It's love that tells you that,
"No, I must first forgive myself because
if I don't forgive myself, then I bring
any doubt, any hatred, any sin to
heaven, this would be unworthy of God.
Okay, I must be the pearl that reflects
the universe, and therefore I must be a
perfect pearl.
Okay, keep on going.
>> In that age when the worthy Titus, with
help from the highest king, avenged the
wounds from which the blood that Judas
sold had flowed,
I had sufficient fame beyond.
That spirit replied,
"I bore the name that lasts the longest
and honors most, but faith was not yet
mine.
So gentle was the spirit of my verse
that Rome drew me, son of Tolomeus, to
her, and there my brow deserved a crown
of myrtle.
On earth my name is still remembered,
Statius. I sang of Thebes and then of
great Achilles. I fell along the way of
that last labor.
The sparks that warmed me, the seeds of
my ardor, were from the holy fire, the
same that gave more than the thousand
poets light and flame.
I speak of the Aeneid.
When I wrote my When I wrote verse, it
was mother to me, it was nurse.
My work without it would not weigh an
ounce.
And to have lived on earth when Virgil
lived, for that I would extend by one
more year the time I owe before my
exile's end."
>> Okay, so Virgil is very impressed by
this man, and so Virgil asks, "Who are
you?" And then the person says, "My name
is Statius, okay? You may not know who I
am, but when Titus was alive" and then
Titus was a Roman emperor who lived
around 70 uh CE. This is important
because Titus was the one who destroyed
the um
the temple, okay? The second temple of
the uh Jews.
Okay, so he's a very important figure in
Christian
mythology.
Um and he's saying that during this
time, and this is this is only like, you
know, 40 years after the death of Jesus,
and Jesus is not very well known at this
point in history. Statius says that I
was a poet, okay? But he was also a
Latin poet. And who was my hero?
Virgil.
Okay? But not only But not only is
Virgil my my hero, [snorts] the Aeneid
was my mother.
She nursed me. She fed me. I aspire to
be Virgil. I want to write the Aeneid.
Okay? So now what what happens is you
have a paradox
created.
Right? Where we just said that Virgil is
in hell because he wrote the Aeneid and
because he's proposing a theory of love
that's not consistent with God.
How is it possible that a son of his, a
student of his, named Statius, how is he
able to ascend to heaven?
Okay?
This is really weird. It's a paradox.
And we'll see a lot of paradoxes in the
Divine Comedy. Okay, you keep on going.
>> These words made Virgil turn to me, and
as he turned, his face, through silence,
said, "Be still.
And yet the power of will cannot do all,
for tears and smiles are both so
faithful to the feelings that have
prompted them that true feeling escapes
the will that would subdue
>> Okay, stop. Okay, all right. So you have
the scene, right? Where Virgil and Dante
are talking to Statius.
And Statius doesn't know who they are.
And having this conversation,
and Virgil's saying to Statius, "Who are
you?" And Statius is saying, "I admire
Virgil the most." And Dante is like, "Oh
my god! Wow! Virgil!"
And so Dante feels tremendous happiness
for both Virgil and for Statius. Virgil
because he's found a fan, and Statius
because he's found his mentor.
What is strange though is Virgil's
reaction. Virgil saying to Dante, "Shut
up, man. I know what you want to do.
I know you want to tell him, but don't
do it.
Keep quiet. I don't want him to know who
I am."
This is This is a paradox.
>> [snorts]
>> This is a paradox. Why would you do
that?
Also, remember Virgil has shown
tremendous respect and admiration to
Statius for being able to cleanse
himself of all his sins and to be able
to ascend to heaven.
Right? So, Dante is so confused by this
that he doesn't actually respond to
Virgil's command to shut up. Virgil's
Dante's actually going to tell Statius
that, "Yes, this is Virgil, man. Keep on
going."
>> But I smiled like a man whose eyes would
signal. At this, the shade was silent,
and he stared with sentiment in the
clearest of my eyes and said,
"So may your trial labor end so
successfully. Do you tell me why just
now your face showed me the flashing of
a smile?"
Now I am held by one side and the other.
One keeps me still, the other conjures
me to speak. But when therefore I sigh,
my master knows why and tells me,
"Do not be afraid to speak, but speak in
answer what he has asked you to tell him
with such earnestness."
At this I answered,
"Ancient spirit, you perhaps are
wondering at the smile I smiled. But I
would have you feel still more
surprised.
He who is guide, who leads my eye on
high, is is that same Virgil from whom
you derived the power to sing of men and
the and of the gods.
Do not suppose my smile had any source
beyond the speech you spoke. Be sure,
it was those words you said of him that
were the cause."
Now he had bent to kiss my teacher's
feet, but Virgil told him,
"Brother, there is no need. You are a
shade. A shade is what you see."
And rising he, "Now you can understand
how much love burns in me for you when I
forget our insubstantiality,
insubstantiality,
treating the shades as one treats solid
things."
>> Okay, all right. So, so sorry. I I was
wrong, okay? So, Dante is sort of stuck,
okay? Because he knows he wants to tell
Statius, but Virgil doesn't want him to
tell Statius. And then Dante looks at
Virgil and Virgil says, "Fine, man. Go
go tell him, okay?" And as you can see,
Statius is ecstatic. And he's so excited
that he forgets that he's actually just
a shade. He has no body. So, he he goes
down and he kisses Virgil's feet. And
Virgil's like, "Stop this, man. You're
just a shade. You're just a shadow. You
can't actually kiss my feet."
And so, this shows both Statius's
excitement, but it also shows Virgil's
embarrassment.
He's embarrassed by all this. He's
mortified, in fact. He He is so
embarrassed by all this. And it's very
confusing.
You've got this huge fan, Statius,
and he's a great person,
and he should be he should be ecstatic
about this. So, why is he so mortified?
And the logic is this, okay? Let's
imagine that
um you guys
take
the great books of me, okay?
And then you go on to America, where you
go to Harvard,
and become a professor of Dante,
okay? And then you come back,
and I don't I don't know that you're now
teaching at Harvard and you're teaching
Dante, but you come back and I'm still
here after 20 years, unfortunately.
And you say to me, "Professor Jiang, I
want to take you out to lunch,
um because you're such an inspiration."
I was like,
"Um, okay, sure. I'm very happy about
this."
And then I asked you, "Hey, where are
you teaching now?" And you say,
"Harvard." I'm like, "Okay, I I need to
go now, guys. Okay, see you later,
okay?" So, this is what's happening
here, where Statius is supposed to be
lower than Virgil. He's supposed to be
Virgil's student, but how is it that
Statius is able to transcend Virgil?
Virgil's still stuck in limbo, but
Statius is going to heaven.
Okay? What happened?
All right, keep on going.
>> [snorts]
[clears throat]
>> Virgil began,
"Love that that is kindled by virtue
will in another find reply, as long as
that love's flame appears without. So,
from the time when Juvenal, descending
among us in hell's limbo, had made plain
the fondness that you felt for me,
my own benevolence towards you has been
much richer than any ever given to a
person when when he's not seen.
Thus, now these years have seemed short.
But tell me, and as friend, forgive me
if excessive candor lets my reins relax,
and as a friend, exchange your words
with me.
How was it that you found within your
breast a place for avarice when you
possessed the wisdom you had nurtured
with such care?"
>> Okay, so Juvenal is another poet. That's
a contemporary of Statius. Okay, so this
is really where it's where Statius is
able to ascend to heaven, but Juvenal
goes to limbo. It's Remember, limbo is a
place not for bad people.
It's It's for people who were born
before Christ or who never really
acknowledged Christ, okay?
So, most people end up in limbo. And so,
Virgil is basically asking Statius,
"How did you end up here in purgatory
when you should be in limbo? This makes
no sense to me."
Right? This is destroying Virgil's
framework for the universe, where you
have to believe in God, you have to
swear allegiance to Christ in order to
ascend to heaven. Okay, keep on going.
>> These words at first brought something
of a smile to Satius. Then he answered,
"Every word you speak to me is a dear
sign of love.
Indeed, because true causes are
concealed, we often face deceptive
reasoning and and things provoke
perplexity in us.
Your question makes me sure that you're
convinced. Perhaps because my circle was
fifth. That in my in the life I once
lived, avarice had been my sin.
Know then that I was far from avarice.
It was my lack of measure thousands of
mouths
months have been have punished.
And if I had not corrected my to my
corrected my assessment by my
understanding what your verses meant
when you, as if enraged by human nature,
exclaimed,
"Why cannot you, oh holy hunger for
gold, restrain the appetite of mortals?"
I now, while rolling weights, know sorry
ghosts.
Then I became aware that hands might
open too wide like wings in spending.
And of this, as of my other sin, I did
repent.
>> Okay, so he's saying, "Yes, I should
be here because of avarice,
but
the issue is not avarice, okay? The
issue is I don't really understand
the universe.
Okay, so it took me 500 years for me to
truly understand the universe and my
place in it. All right, keep on going.
>> Um
>> Sorry, let let me uh
All right, sorry.
Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> How many are to rise again with heads
cropped close, whom ignorance prevents
from reaching repentance in and at the
end of life?
And know that when a sin is countered by
another fault directly opposite to it,
then here both sins see their green
wither.
Thus, I join those who pay for avarice
in my purgation,
though what brought me here was
prodigality,
its opposite.
Now, when you sang the savage words of
those twin sorrows of Jocasta, said the
singer of the bucolic poems, it does not
seem from those notes struck by you and
Cleo there,
that you would yet turn faithful to the
faith without which righteous works do
not suffice.
If that is so, then what sun or what
candles drew you from darkness to to so
that in their wake you set your sails
behind the fisherman?
>> Okay, so Virgil's confused by all of
this. Like, you're not a Christian. Why
are you here? He went on going,
>> And he said to him, "You were the first
to send me to drink within Parnassus'
caves, and you the first who, after God,
enlightened me.
You did as he who goes by night and
carries lamp behind him.
He is of no help to his own self, but
teaches those who follow.
When you declared,
the ages are renewed, justice in man's
first time on Earth return, from heaven
a new progeny descends,
through you I was a poet and through you
a Christian.
But that you may see more plainly, I'll
set my hand to color what I sketch.
Disseminated by the messengers of the
eternal kingdom, the truth faith by then
had penetrated all the world, and the
new preachers preached in such accord
with what you'd said and I have just
repeated, that I was drawn into
frequenting them.
Then they appeared to me to be so
saintly that that when Domitian
Domitian persecuted them, my own laments
accompanied their grief, and while I
could, as long as I had life, I helped
them.
And their honest practices made me the
saint full of all other sects."
>> Okay, so again,
um
Virgil's asking Statius, like, "How are
you here? You're not a Christian." And
what Statius is saying is like, "Yes,
it's true that I never publicly
converted to Christianity,
but I was always I was always
sympathetic towards Christianity, and
it's your book, the Aeneid,
in which made me convinced
that Christianity is a good religion,
okay? For you, I was a poet, and for
you, a Christian."
Right? But But Virgil said that uh
Virgil's Aeneid
um goes against the teachings of the
universe.
So, what this is telling us is that
Statius
purposely misread Virgil.
He loved Virgil for for his poetry, but
instead of believing Virgil,
he in his heart chose to believe in
himself.
Okay? He chooses his own intuition.
And that's what saved him.
All right.
Keep on going.
>> Before within my poem, I led the Greeks
onto the streams of Thebes, I was
baptized.
But out of fear, I was a secret
Christian Christian, and for a long time
showed myself as pagan.
For this half-heartedness, for more than
four centuries, I circled the fourth
circle.
And now may you, who lifted up the lid
that hid from you the good of which I
speak, while time is left us as we
climb,
tell me where is our ancient Terence and
Caecilius Caecilius and Plautus? Where
is Varius, if you know?
Tell me if they are damned and in what
quarter.
All these and Persius, I and many
others, my guide replied,
are with that Greek to whom the Muses
gave their gifts in greatest measure.
Our place is the is the blind prison,
its first circle, and there we often
talk about the mountain [snorts] where
those who are nursed as always dwell.
>> Okay, stop. Okay, all right. So,
um Statius is saying I was a secret
Christian, okay? So, I was secretly
baptized and I became a secret
Christian. But, if you're a secret
Christian, are you really a Christian?
Um so, again, [snorts]
there's no there ain't there are many
ways that you can interpret this, okay?
But, obviously, this is a paradox. And
this is confusing Virgil.
And it's telling us that maybe
everything that Virgil says is not
correct.
Okay? This is actually subtly
um and with nuance undermining the
argument of Virgil.
Okay? All right. So, now we are moving
towards the final
uh part of our tour when Dante is able
to ascend to the mountain top where
Beatrice will come and uh meet him,
okay?
Keep on going.
>> [snorts]
>> I have at times seen all the eastern sky
becoming rose as day began seen adorns
and ruby blue the rest of heaven.
And seeing the sun's face rise so veiled
that it was tempered by the mist and
could permit the eye to look at length
upon it.
So, within a cloud of flowers that were
cast by the angelic hands and then rose
up and then fell back outside in the
chariot, a woman showed herself to me.
Above a white veil, she was crowned with
olive boughs.
Her cape was green, her dress her dress
beneath flame red.
Within her presence, I had once been
used to feeling trembling, wonder,
dissolution, but that was long ago.
Still, though my soul, now she was
veiled, could not see her directly, by
way of hidden force that she could move,
I felt the mighty power of old love.
>> Okay. So, Dante hasn't seen Beatrice in
a long time, in decades. And his his
heart has loved Beatrice all his life.
And so,
he's really excited
that Beatrice is before him, okay? His
entire body shakes. And his first
response is he wants Virgil to share in
his happiness
because he owes everything to Virgil.
It's Virgil that brought him through
inferno and brought him through
purgatory so that he may finish his
journey with Beatrice, okay? So, that's
what Dante wants. He wants to share his
happiness with his teacher,
um,
Virgil. He got away.
>> [snorts]
>> As soon as that deep forest has struck
my vision, the power of that, when I had
not yet left my boyhood, had already
transfixed me.
I turned around into my left, just as a
little child afraid or in distress will
hurry to his mother, anxiously, to say
to Virgil,
"I am left with less than one drop of my
blood that does not tremble. I recognize
the
>> [snorts]
>> the signs of the old flame.
But Virgil had deprived us of himself,
Virgil, the gentlest father,
Virgil, he to whom I gave myself for my
salvation.
And even all our ancient mother lost was
not enough to keep my cheeks, though
washed with dew, from darkening again
with tears."
>> Okay. So, he is extremely happy. He's
ecstatic to see
Beatrice. He turns to Virgil. And he's
assuming that Virgil was beside him. And
he says, he he wants to tell him how
happy he is. And then when he sees that
Virgil is not there,
Virgil has disappeared,
he becomes despondent. His ecstasy
becomes,
um, a depression,
okay? That's how high he's got and
that's how low he's fallen. Because all
he wants is share share happiness with
Virgil, but Virgil has run away. So this
is a paradox again, okay? The Divine
Comedy is nothing but paradoxes.
Why did Virgil run away?
Right?
Okay? This makes absolutely no sense.
First of all,
Virgil should be proud and happy
for Dante, right? He loves Dante, Dante
wants to be with Beatrice again, and
Virgil made it happen.
You would think that he would want to
see Dante and Beatrice together again,
okay? That's one problem. Another
problem is that
Beatrice was the one who asked Virgil to
take Dante on this journey. So Beatrice
owes him a favor.
And you would think that Virgil can say,
"Hey,
um
Beatrice, I did you this favor, so maybe
you can do me a favor and like get me to
heaven."
Right?
This is like really strange. And the
third
uh problem
is that
this is like really awkward, [laughter]
okay?
This is like really strange.
The least you can do is basically say to
Beatrice, "Listen, I brought Dante here
and now he's yours." Okay, that's as
polite you can do. This is like not
typical of
uh Virgil. So this leads this leads a
huge question
in our mind as to why Virgil did this.
Okay? Keep Keep on going?
>> Dante, though Virgil's leaving [snorts]
you, do not yet weep. Do not weep yet.
You'll need your tears for what another
sword must yet inflict.
Just like an admiral who goes stern and
proud to see the officers who guide the
other ships encouraging their tasks,
so on the left side of the chariot, I
turned around when I heard my name,
which of necessity I transcribe here.
I saw the lady who at first appeared to
me beneath the veils of the angelic
flowers look at me across the stream.
Although the veil she wore
>> Wait, stop. Okay, all right. Okay. So,
what is interesting is Beatrice is
saying to Dante,
Virgil's gone. Forget him.
He's not important. What's important is
your mission in paradise. Focus on that,
Dante. Let's forget Virgil.
All right? Let's forget him.
And this creates a huge paradox in our
minds.
What is going on here? Why did Virgil
run away?
Okay?
And again, you can interpret this as
many ways as you want, and there's no
right or wrong answer, but one
interpretation is that
Virgil is first and foremost
um he believes he is right.
He is in hell because he believes that
he should be there.
No one put him there. He just put
himself there. And he believes he should
be there because
God can only let in those who are
Christians, okay? And along the way, we
discover that's not actually true. Cato,
who is not a Christian, is a guardian of
purgatory. Statius, who is a secret
Christian, he's able to ascend to
heaven. So, clearly Virgil's framework
is wrong.
Virgil does not want to see Dante and
Beatrice together again.
Okay? Because the relationship between
Dante
and Beatrice
is the opposite
all through our relationship between
Virgil
and Dido, okay?
Both are literary creations.
The difference is that Dante put
Beatrice into paradise.
>> [snorts]
>> Whereas Virgil put Dido into hell,
right? In the inferno.
Dante believes that love is funda-
fundamentally about giving.
Whereas Virgil believes that love is
funda- fundamentally about receiving and
conquering.
Okay? So, these are two major
dichotomies.
And
Virgil does not want to see the power of
Dante's love for Beatrice, where
Beatrice rejected him, Beatrice was
never with him, but Dante loved kept on
loving her, okay? Dante was willing to
give. He understood that living that
true love is about sharing, is about
bestowing, is about giving yourself.
Whereas Virgil has always claimed that
love is about taking, about consuming,
about controlling.
Okay?
So, that's why Virgil had to leave
because he did not want to be wrong.
OKAY?
HE DID NOT want his worldview to be
destroyed. So, he'd rather burn in hell
for all of eternity
than to say,
"I am wrong."
Okay?
All right, any questions?
All right, so we will finish the Divine
Comedy next Wednesday.